[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
hoy nos acompaña en este espacio el
presidente de Costa Rica el señor
Rodrigo Chávez un gusto saludarle un
gusto saludarla Rosa a usted y a toda la
audiencia de su programa encantado de
estar aquí Señor Chávez usted nos
atiende en el marco de la Cumbre
iberoamericana y de hecho en este en
esta ocasión ha asistido el alto
representante de la Unión Europea para
los asuntos exteriores con quien usted
acaba de tener una reunión bilateral Qué
espera Costa Rica de esta Promesa de
acercamiento entre la Unión Europea y
América Latina y en particular para su
país Costa Rica es un país que conoce el
Real politik del mundo en este momento
de centro gravitacional de la atención
geopolítica de Europa y de los Estados
Unidos está en Ucrania y en Rusia lo
entendemos perfectamente
ese es un tema que puede definir el
futuro de muchas cosas de la Unión
Europea de la otan y de temas muy muy
sensibles en la geopolítica mundial y en
el futuro de la humanidad por tanto
entendemos que haya habido un
distanciamiento
el llamado que le ha hecho Costa Rica y
creo que los otros jefes de estados que
estuvimos aquí a la Unión Europea yo se
lo dije directamente
a España que va a asumir la presidencia
es que tienen que rebalancear un poco
esa atención entendemos que esté ahí
pero no es dándole la espalda a América
Latina y hay iberoamérica que se puede
arreglar el problema de de Rusia de la
invasión rusa e ilegal sobre el pueblo
ucraniano entonces
Ese es el llamado y es el expectativa y
que esperan concretamente de esta de
esta petición de recentrar la atención
en América Latina no esperamos más
cooperación mejor diálogo diplomático
y más inversiones extranjera más
comercio y las cosas que
unen a las naciones
sin que haya un abandono Total que se
siente un poquito
producto de la emergencia en Europa y
precisamente usted acaba de estar en
Francia para
cooperar en la que será la próxima
cumbre de los océanos Qué espera de esta
cooperación material de protección
medioambiental Bueno yo creo que mi
generación nosotros los viejos y tenemos
que tener muy clara Cuál es nuestra
responsabilidad histórica
nuestra responsabilidad histórica es que
las próximas generaciones vivan en mi
caso ninguna Costa Rica mejor pero en el
caso del mundo en un mundo mejor y Eso
incluye un mundo donde el ambiente
permita al ser humano vivir con armonía
con la naturaleza con salud el mar es
una parte importantísima de eso el
océano hay solo un océano Rosa mentira
que los océanos y los peces migrantes
conocen de fronteras y ahí es donde
nosotros junto a Francia queremos decir
es nuestra responsabilidad histórica
tenemos que actuar ya el tiempo se nos
está acabando la gran belleza desde mi
punto de vista de Costa Rica
participando junto a una nación tan
poderosa como Francia en la organización
de esta Cumbre es que todo lo que
podamos decir Costa Rica ya lo hizo
cubrimos de bosque nuestro territorio
terrestre
eliminamos
la deforestación Tropical doblamos la
cobertura de bosque ya tenemos 30% de
nuestros mares protegidos y estamos
trabajando muy duro en temas como
plástico la pesca ilegal no regulada y
no reportada y vamos como ejemplo a
decirle al mundo no solo se puede sino
que ya lo hemos hecho y precisamente una
de las Bueno una cuestión que va un poco
en contradicción a lo que usted me
comenta es que usted dice que ratificar
el acuerdo de escazú por parte de Costa
Rica no está en su agenda Por qué Porque
el acuerdo de escasez no tiene ningún
sentido económico no tiene ningún
sentido social y no tiene ningún sentido
de protección de la naturaleza Más allá
de lo que Costa Rica ha hecho el acuerdo
que fue impulsado por un gobierno
con la ideología totalmente diferente le
permitiría a cualquier persona
atrasar un proyecto de construir una
fábrica de tecnología perfectamente
sostenible para darle empleo a los
jóvenes diciendo Ah yo como individuo
tengo la legitimidad de hacer que mis
preocupaciones ambientales se han
escuchadas eso no es orden es caos es
decir usted considera que en estos
momentos en Costa Rica se debe priorizar
las garantías para la inversión
económica por encima de lo que serían
las garantías medioambientales miren
Costa Rica considero considero yo y este
gobierno lo considera Rosa que no existe
una dicotomía y una contradicción entre
el desarrollo y progreso económico
especialmente para darle oportunidad de
laborales a los jóvenes y la de la
naturaleza Por qué el acuerdo de escazú
le otorgaría
protecciones especiales a personas por
pertenecer a un grupo sobre el resto de
la sociedad costarricense todo lo que el
acuerdo de escaso llama ya está cubierto
en nuestra legislación actual de una
manera adecuada y la prueba está en que
Costa Rica Ha logrado proteger su
ambiente tenemos más parques nacionales
como protección de nuestro territorio
que ningún país del mundo y la
protección del océano el acuerdo de
escazú fue una pose política que no
hubiera logrado nada y la carta
medioambiental iberoamericana que se ha
firmado en esta Cumbre aporta algo a la
protección medioambiental en Costa Rica
mire Costa Rica es el país que más
avanzado está
y nos encanta que muchas de las cosas
que nosotros ya hemos hecho otros países
las hagan pero repito el acuerdo de
escazú era ponerle un lazo un moño
decorativo a lo que Costa Rica ya ha
hecho con Consecuencias negativas para
el empleo y el desarrollo económico
precisamente hablando de desarrollo
económico usted ha trabajado muchos años
en el Banco Mundial y es presidente de
un país de los más endeudados de la
región y de hecho uno de los ejes de
esta Cumbre era
un llamado de ciertos países a cambiar
las normas del sistema financiero
internacional para que sea más fácil
acceder a ciertos préstamos créditos
internacionales por partes por parte de
países de la región usted En qué medida
comparte esta necesidad mire el alto
endeudamiento de Costa Rica no es
producto de los organismos y financieros
internacionales ha sido el longitud de
una irresponsabilidad fiscal enorme en
los últimos 30 años donde Costa Rica se
endeudaba para dar aumentos de sueldos a
los empleados públicos dar pensiones de
lujos de lujo a personas que no
cotizaron lo suficiente para recibir
esos beneficios del resto de la sociedad
y nuestro endeudamiento es nuestra
responsabilidad y mi gobierno es el
primer gobierno en décadas que empieza a
amortizar y a reducir la deuda pública
eso es un punto el otro punto es que sí
las organizaciones financieras
internacionales
necesitan una reforma profunda para
ayudar a los países hacer las
inversiones que se necesitan para
desarrollarse económicamente para
proteger nuestro ambiente Disculpe
porque no no tenemos mucho tiempo y me
gustaría tocar otro tema que es el de la
seguridad y es que usted ayer delante de
la comunidad iberoamericana hizo un
llamado a pagar el fuego en Haití a qué
se refiere exactamente que cree que se
debería hacer en Haití teniendo en
cuenta que Costa Rica es un país así sin
ejército Costa Rica es un país sin
ejército sin un solo soldado sin un solo
avión de guerra o
este barco armado
Haití es un estado fallido en este
momento se encuentran compitiendo por el
control político y físico de Puerto
Príncipe por el Puerto Príncipe por
ejemplo tres bandas criminales
y mientras no se vuelva a instaurar la
institucionalidad de ese país no se van
a poder hacer elecciones no se va a
poder volver a dar la protección de un
estado funcional a la población de Haití
mucha gente dice no primero hay que
llamar a elecciones para luego
intervenir eso es como decir de qué
color vamos a pintar la casa y gastar
tiempo discutiendo eso cuando la casa
está incendiándose hay que apagar el
fuego y luego diseñar Y eso requiere la
intervención de las Naciones Unidas con
todos los recursos necesarios para poner
orden y desarmar estos grupos Es decir
usted su plan exactamente su llamado
sería una intervención digamos militar
sería una intervención con los recursos
de fuerza que permita desarmar a estos
grupos criminales que han tomado control
del país Costa Rica no puede contribuir
porque nosotros no tenemos militares
pero lo que estamos diciendo es a quien
le interese el bienestar de los
haitianos y que sí Tenga sus recursos
hablar de elecciones hablar de sentarse
a negociar cuando no hay una contraparte
legítima no es la ruta lógica para curar
el problema que vive ese pueblo que
además está sufriendo tremendamente y
que ha sufrido a lo largo de su historia
más allá de lo que un costarricense cree
es justo que hayan sufrido que es mucho
el señor de Rodrigo Chávez nos quedan
muchísimos temas por fuera Ojalá
tengamos la ocasión de conversar
nuevamente pero muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros en 24 Muchísimas
gracias a usted Muchísimas gracias a su
audiencia Y cuando guste con mucho gusto
conversaré con en su programa de nuevo
gracias a ustedes Muchísimas gracias por
su atención saben que pueden continuar
con más información en 34 y 34.com